celle attaques contre la députée que je
suis parce que pour ces gens c'est
insupportable qu'une femme noire puisse
être député de la république pour eux
nous sommes des corps étrangers
littéralement qu'il faut faire émigrer
renvoyée en afrique et donc c'est aussi
pour ça que je tenais est là avec mon
écharpe pour réaffirmer le fait que j'ai
été élu et que je suis député de la
nation française et j'en suis fier et
que c'est parce que je suis dégoûté que
je suis aussi insoumise et je suis
insoumise parce que je suis député et
que c'est
c'est cette résistance et c'est
insoumission que je voulais réaffirmé en
étant ici est donc la meilleure réponse
est d'être présent de s'engager de
militer de résister de dire non et de
pas se taire parce qu'en réalité ce qui
leur pose un problème c'est qu'on prenne
la parole en fait parce que tant qu on
ne disait rien tant qu'on subit tant
qu'on est essentielle à faire marcher
l'économie et que on en demande pas trop
on n'est tolérée mais à partir du moment
où on ouvre on ouvre la voir et on dit
non c'est ça qui est intolérable pour
alors danièle obono donc a décidé de
porter plainte mais qui estime qu'au
delà de la bataille juridique il est
aussi une bataille politique qui doit
être mené pour dénoncer ce qu'elle
appelle un racisme systémique en france